the dance of dragons a true telling by
Grand Mr Monken being a history of the
war of Targaryen succession between the
princess renera and aegon second of his
name that nearly destroyed the realm
do you know what the realm is
thousand Blades of aegon's enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and over
in a scene that has to be one of the
most heartbreaking moments in all of
Game of Thrones Shireen Baratheon
describes what happens in House of the
dragon as her father Stannis listens
right before he has her burned alive at
the stake by melisandro you had to
choose
you've chosen
I wouldn't have chosen either
saw the choosing sides that made
everything so horrible viserys and his
daughter rhaenyra want to be the first
ones who break that standard
unfortunately viserys's Circumstances
had a major effect on his line of
succession now because viserys was still
considered a young man he remarried and
as you all know he married his
daughter's best friend Alison Hightower
like we hear Shireen saying that scene
this will lead to the downfall of House
Targaryen
the iron throne
when people started declaring for one of
them or the other their fight divided
the kingdoms in Two Brothers Four
Brothers
Dragon spot dragons
by the time it was over
thousands were dead
and there was a disaster for the
targaryens as well
they never truly recovered
as rhaenyra and aegon fight over the
Iron Throne we will see the mighty House
of the Dragon nearly lose everything
neither runnera nor aegon will want to
give up their claim to the Iron Throne
resulting in the demise of almost every
single Targaryen as well as their dragon
the devastating effects of the dance of
the Dragons will be felt all the way up
to the Game of Thrones when Daenerys
Targaryen is born into a family that no
longer has any dragons at all
the dance of dragons
the story of the fight between renira
Targaryen and her heart by the Reagan
for control of the Seven Kingdoms
Dance of the dragons
a stupid name for a Targaryen Civil War
where my ancestors danced away my
Birthright
Before the War House Targaryen counted
18 Dragons by the end we had two and
nearly as few targaryens we would never
be as powerful or as feared again
foreign
[Music]
thank you